here's a question from Alex Robinson
about the death star in the movie star
wars thanks for clarifying this is the
death star blow up the planet Alderaan
I've said it what setting aside the
question of how a thing would be
possible what would happen to our solar
system if the Empire blew up say Mars
yeah that's a great question so it's
really simple first how would you one go
about blowing up a planet yeah what you
can do is look at what's holding the
planet together there's all the gravity
yeah and there's all the all the tensile
strength of all the solid matter that is
the planet yeah and here's how to blow
something up you ask yourself how much
energy is keeping it together mm-hmm
then you put more than that amount of
energy into the object mm-hmm it will
explode soon so more than whatever so
more than the gravitational yep so you
finally given calculate that that's
physics 102 right not physics 101 won't
blow apart that's a pretty that's a
quite an accelerated sciences calculate
what's called the binding energy of the
planet all right and it's a
gravitational binding it's gravity keeps
it together you want to overcome the
gravity that's holding it together
calculate that how much energy is it now
you have a device that can pump that
energy into your planet and have that
planet absorb the energy rather than
have the energy come out the other side
it will completely destroy the planet to
smithereens
entirely so that's how one would go
about it if you did it to Mars we'd lose
our Curiosity rover that's fine and
discovering science there but but it
wouldn't affect us that much
I would affect our Rover no no of course
what was lose mean I mean I mean our
physical wealthy age our mental
emotional a knowledge well-being we we
will continue to warp at the Sun and
Mars will have essentially no effect on
us will will parts of it land here and
the decibel people then gain powers
there will be Mars debris scattered all
over the solar system those sub Mars of
you will land everywhere yes okay
eventually it'll land everywhere and
would radiate kids and make them power
no because Mars
radioactive well alright well well well
at least we get some